in this video we will explain what would
the next generation of hashida look like
we'll talk about how strong would they
be and what powers they would have we
also have a custom drawing for every
future hashida so you definitely want to
watch it till the end let's start with
the future flower pillar kanao suyuri
our girl kaneo has been through a lot
but she managed to recover with the help
of the cultural sisters due to the
trauma she endured hanau bottled up all
her emotions and struggled to make any
kind of decisions by herself it was kane
the former flower hashida who gave her a
coin and suggested that she flip it to
decide which path she should follow
slowly as she grew up in the care of the
kocho sisters kaneo started expressing
her emotions and started making
decisions as well in fact kanao's deep
hatred for demons and her decision to
become a demon slayer was of her own
volition and guess what she was one of
the strongest demon slayers at the time
of the final selection and is also a
student to tu hashida that itself sets
her apart from the rest of the demon
slayers so how would she do as the
future hashira as the new flower hashida
kanawa would share some resemblance with
the kocho sisters as she was trained by
both of them she would possess abilities
and skills that would far exceed the
previous hashida currently kano is
extremely fast such that she can easily
out speed both inosuke and tanjiro so we
can only imagine how fast she would be
as a hashida additionally if we talk
about her skills kanoa would be a master
swordsman much like the late flower
hashira kanai however she will surely
outshine the previous hashida as her
swordsmanship was admired by doma as
well whom she defeated with the help of
inosuke moving forward kano uses the
flower breathing style which she learned
and mastered simply by observing the
late hashida kane our future hashida
would be exceptional at using various
forms of the breathing style having a
better grip on it than ever before most
importantly she would master the final
form of the flower breathing style
equinoctial vermilion eye which is a
technique that significantly increases
the kinetic vision of the user and
allowing the user to have incredible
perception however the final form is
quite dangerous and can cause blindness
in the user on the other hand a skilled
demon slayer like kanao would
considerably reduce the damage taken by
mastering the technique what's more
kanawa was also trained by shinobu the
insect hashida therefore she might
possess some of her medicinal
capabilities as well and would take over
the butterfly mansion in short hanau
would be showcasing a beautiful mixture
of the abilities taught to her by the
kocho sisters while effectively
delivering a unique color of her own to
the position of the flower hashira up
next we have a remarkably unique demon
slayer genya shinazugawa what's so
different about him our boy genya had an
unimaginable tragic past and belonged to
a family of nine one day a demon killed
off the shinazugawa siblings and badly
scarred genya sanami the win hashida and
the older brother of genya tried to
protect him while he escaped and tried
to look for a doctor upon coming back
and witnessing sanami kill off their
mother who was the demon behind the
killings of their siblings genya
misunderstood the situation and thought
that his brother was a murderer and
assumed that his siblings were killed
off by a wolf instead the terrible event
caused the shinazugawa brothers to have
a broken relationship throughout the
anime although genya realized his
mistake and tried to get closer to his
brother by becoming a demon slayer
sanami never acknowledged him making him
realize just how weak he was compared to
others however genya continued to work
hard to become a hashida and get closer
to his older brother so how powerful
would genya be as the future hashida
despite not being able to use a
breathing technique like his fellow
demon slayers genya managed to not only
survive but kick butt with the help of
the repetitive action technique taught
to him by giome himejima the guy trained
under the strongest hashida of the
current generation so he's bound to be
incredibly tough even though without
possessing a breathing technique
furthermore genya can temporarily obtain
unique demonic powers depending on the
demon he consumes do you know what that
means as a hashida genya would master
this technique and would practically be
invincible especially if he consumes any
part of muzan kibutsuji the future
hashira would be an exceptional user of
the blood demon art similar to that of
nezuko's and would create several
techniques of his own as genya can
create bullets from his flesh he could
learn to create many different weapons
and objects to tackle demons effectively
additionally kenya is an expert marksman
and a master swordsman making him an
exceptional and brilliant hashida of the
next generation dania has set an example
of his own by possessing unique
abilities and honing them to the point
that he could easily attack an upper
moon without even being a breath user
now that's something even the strongest
demon slayers would struggle with let's
talk about the boar-headed boy nosuke
hashibira on the surface inosuke seems
to be quite reckless and carefree but
that's far from the truth growing up
inosuke has suffered from quite a few
scars himself explaining his eccentric
behavior throughout the series inosuke's
mother escaped from his abusive father
and was taken in by the upper moon rank
2 demons cult upon realizing the reality
of the situation she was in inosuke's
mother ran away and tried to protect her
son by throwing him in the river
desperately hoping he would survive
unfortunately in the end she was unable
to save herself and was devoured by doma
later inosuke was adopted by boars and
brought up by them such that he wears
the head of his dead adopted boar mother
although inosuke didn't receive any kind
of proper training from a hashida like
the rest of his teammates did his
strength has been acknowledged by many
including both humans and demons so the
question stands how would an accenture
person like inosuke be as the future
hashira the boar-headed guy has this
obsession with doing his best and
constantly improving such that he
considers brutal conditions and torture
as a training method the desire for
consistent improvement may make him one
of the strongest hashida in the future
having several new tricks and techniques
up his sleeves what's more the guy
developed his own breathing technique
known as the beast breathing due to the
harsh conditions he had to face while
living in the woods that's how good he
is combine his insane instinct and
reflexes with formal training for a
hashida inosuke would reach a whole new
level becoming unimaginably powerful as
a hashida he would heavily rely on
breathing forms that are connected to
his exceptional swordsmanship skills
most probably the new techniques he
learns will further heighten his
perception and reflexes allowing him to
efficiently tackle any demon by
identifying their locations and their
weaknesses in a matter of seconds much
like genya enosuke would set new
standards for the next generation of
demon slayers proving that some fancy
breeding form is not needed to be strong
his dedication to training and
improvement would be admirable for most
demon slayers up next we have a fan
favorite zanitsu agatsumi we know how
passionate zenitsu can be when it comes
to girls and finding a wife which caused
them many problems in the past zenitu
never had anyone to properly guide him
as a child so he ended up getting
scammed by a girl he dearly loved poor
guy was left drowning in debt and was
offered financial help by jigoro
kuwajima the previous thunder hashira
jigoro then also took it upon himself to
train zenitsu as a swordsman the
thunder-breathing user suffers from
self-esteem issues throughout the anime
and doesn't believe that he's capable of
killing anything but a bug however he
managed to slay some of the strongest
demons out there and what's even more
interesting he did all of that while
being unconscious so let's talk about
zenitsu as the future hashida how would
he be and would he overcome his
weaknesses despite being a coward with
multiple self-esteem issues zenitu is an
extraordinarily powerful thunderbreeding
user and a master swordsman much like
the other characters he would add a
different flavor of his own to the
position of the thunder hashira offering
a unique set of skills and abilities he
would grow up to be the most mature and
influential person which may seem
impossible at the moment but he will
eventually become more confident
competent and mature although zenitu's
main specialty is that he has perfectly
mastered one form of the thunder
breathing style as a hashida he would
learn the remaining forms as well this
is because zenith's nerves and
self-esteem issues prevent him from
unleashing his full power as he slowly
grows and becomes more confident he will
have no trouble learning the remaining
forms of thunder breathing and wouldn't
need to fall asleep to fight any demon
what's more with how talented zenitu is
he would develop various techniques
linked to his heightened senses and
incredible speed and reflexes overall he
would make a killer thunder hashira and
his growth would surely bring joy to all
the fans finally we have our main
character heart of the fandom tanjiro
kamado tanjido had an unimaginable tough
time throughout the series being the
eldest child he's endured a lot of
hardships for his family he was quite
young when his father died but he took
it upon himself to protect his family
and became the sole breadwinner for them
tangido learned coal burning and sold
charcoal in nearby villages and towns to
earn money for his family one day while
he was working tanjito's entire family
was killed by muzan and only nezuko was
left alive imagine a 13 year old kid
witnessing his entire family covered in
blood how traumatic would that be for
him despite the terrible events he saw
tanjido still tried to save nezuko and
did whatever he could to help her become
a human again tangido went through
extreme training to become a demon
slayer to avenge his family his only aim
was to kill the demon who attacked his
family except it was the demon king
himself who did the deed leading to
tanjido pushing himself to his limits to
fight on equal footing with him we
already know how incredibly strong
tanjido is as a demon slayer so how
would he be as the future hashira as the
next water hashira or possibly the sun
hashira tanjido would probably be much
stronger than the previous hashida since
tanjiro has learned two different
breathing styles the water breathing and
the sun breathing he would have a large
set of unique abilities by the time he
becomes a hashida as the new hashida
tanjido would share an extreme
resemblance with the first breath user
yorichi tsugikuni he would perfectly
master all the forms of hinokami kagura
to the point that he could manipulate
two breeding styles to create new forms
of his choice furthermore kanjiro has
always been a natural talent when it
comes to combat and he possesses
extraordinary senses as well which
allowed him to fight against gyotomioca
in the beginning however as a hashida
that isn't the only attribute he would
possess tangier would also set an
example for the upcoming generation
through his kind and empathetic nature
and also his undaunted will and spirit
that allowed him to reach where he is
now overall tanjiro kamado would be an
exceptional hashtag and possibly the
strongest ever he would be admired and
respected by many people around the
world and that's exactly what he
deserves for being so brave and
remaining unhinged through all the
obstacles he faced click on this video
where we covered the entire story of
muzan kibutsuji go on click on it i
promise it's an excellent video